i am so ready for a tricia baby hey
everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by billbar
and we'll be taking another look at
trisha paytas pregnancy edition but
first let me tell you what my sponsor
billboard i'm saying it and i'm saying
it again these bars are really really
good really
i mean most of them i feel like are
chalk masquerading as some kind of
health food but i like these bars
because they taste like chocolate and
bonus they've got a lot of protein so
we're cracking into a brand new box here
folks oh
and you know what
i got the puffs i got the puffs i got
the puffs a lot of you guys in the
comment section asked me about the puffs
[Applause]
these are next level good oh my goodness
okay banana cream pie
what am i gonna do what am i gonna do
coconut marshmallow where are we
churro oh
sure
oh
oh oh
oh we're going with the churro this bad
boy
has 17 grams
of protein
[Music]
so good if you like marshmallows you're
going to
die
when you taste a billboard puff
so like i usually have one of these
before bed or if i want to do this as
like a post-workout snack i will throw
in some fruit or put it on top of my
oats it's so good so if you guys want to
try these out yourself check out my link
in the description and use my promo code
abbiesharp15 for 15 off of your order
and you can pause the screen or look at
the description to check out my
disclaimer including a trigger warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating so as
always feel free to skip this video if
it's not supportive to your journey as
we will be specifically talking about
eds and if you are not already
subscribed hit that sub button and
follow me over on tick tock and
instagram at abby's kitchen
i'm excited about this one i'm really
really excited about this video alright
so trisha paytas is no stranger here on
my channel so if you missed my previous
review of trisha you can check that out
right here today we're going to be
focusing on trisha's very exciting
announcement that she's going to become
a mom
yeah yeah
we love that for her so we're going to
be discussing her controversial eating
habits in the context of a healthy
pregnancy
[Music]
i first and foremost want to
congratulate trisha and her hubby on
their incoming bundle of joy and also
wish her all the best on her motherhood
journey with that said given what we
know about trisha and her relationship
with food i have a few concerns that i
want to dive into today and discuss some
strategies for carrying out a healthy
pregnancy especially when struggling
with disordered eating but for starters
let's first jump into pregnancy food
safety but i looked it up and like
yeah you're not supposed to have
soft serve and i've had it a few times
obviously i got my blood work done today
because of the risk of listerine so i
have a whole blog post on potential
foods to avoid in pregnancy and the
rational or research for or against them
linked below now some foods on the no-no
list like a lot of alcohol or high
mercury fish have actual established
risks in substantial quantities but
other foods like soft-serve ice cream
for example have a more theoretical risk
because these foods carry an above
average risk for foodborne illness so
basically pregnancy suppresses the
immune system and obviously an unborn
baby's immune system is undeveloped so
they are particularly fragile to any
potential infection so if an old
unsanitary soft-serve machine has not
had its pipes cleaned for a while and is
therefore harboring harmful bacteria and
a pregnant woman and a non-pregnant
woman were both to have contaminated ice
cream the non-pregnant woman maybe would
just suffer a little tummy upset
theoretically whereas the outcome for
the pregnant woman or baby may be more
severe now not all soft serve is gonna
make you sick same with sushi or lettuce
greens or undercooked eggs but if you
were to get sick baby can get sick so if
you do want to play it extra safe i
suggest opting for a non-custard-based
store-bought ice cream instead as soon
as i found out green juices could carry
like bacteria it's like hey no not that
anymore we're going from the store so
the safety of a fresh pressed juice will
depend on whether or not it's being
pasteurized which basically kills
bacteria by exposing the juice to high
heat for a short period of time
unpasteurized juice that hasn't been
exposed to this process may carry more
bacteria and potentially increase the
risk of listeria so this is why it's
really important to look at the label to
ensure that what you're buying is
pasteurized and the same goes for things
like milk cheese or anything that uses
raw eggs like mayo or salad dressing i
got some edamame we got some oysters
okay so the oysters are a bit concerning
here as raw shellfish or really any
other type of raw meat or seafood can
increase the risk of salmonella or
toxoplasma infection ain't nobody got
time for this as for the sushi things
like california rolls would be
considered a safer option as they don't
contain any raw fish and the crab meat
isn't high in mercury compared to other
sushi grade fish options like ahi tuna
which are higher in mercury and should
be avoided or limited during pregnancy
now some of these food restrictions are
definitely hard for all pregnant people
but they can be particularly triggering
for folks with histories of disordered
eating so i do want to discuss those
implications for tricia as well
it's scary to have like disordered
eating and getting pregnant because on
one hand especially when i have a binge
eating where i just eat a bunch and i
eat nothing and like
it was crazy when i first got pregnant i
was like i need to eat eat and then i'd
like make myself so it was like i mean i
got under control i had i had to see a
therapist because within the first few
days that i found out i was pregnant i
was like then i was freaking out i was
like okay i need to go like only eat
like greens you know it's hard so for
starters i really want to take a moment
to debunk the age-old adage that
pregnant women need to eat for two well
yes we do require more calories during
pregnancy to support our growing baby
bump it is generally equivalent to like
two extra snacks or an extra small meal
in the day there's no need to double
your calories or eat eat eat until
you're sick but i'm also mindful of the
fact that trisha's need to eat a bunch
and then eat nothing also comes from her
disordered eating history and this is
even reflected in her pregnancy content
where she goes from posting her usual
mukbangs to them eating just like a big
bowl of spinach and not much else for a
lot of folks with complicated
relationships with food or histories
with disordered eating pregnancy can be
an extremely triggering time not only
are you experiencing rapid changes in
your body but you may also be having
strong food aversions or cravings that
may be throwing your usual hunger cues
and diet rules totally out of whack and
pregnancy symptoms can make it really
challenging and confusing to heal your
relationship with food while also trying
to be as healthy as possible to support
the baby when i spoke to my dietitian
colleague crystal carques on how to
approach pregnancy and folks with a
history of disordered eating she
suggested that it's important to create
structure around eating to help food
feel less chaotic and to optimize
nutrition as much as possible so this
might look like having set mealtimes
spaced out throughout the day with
balanced nutrient-dense meals that
prioritize the vitamins and minerals
that i'm going to discuss in a moment it
would also be highly beneficial to reach
out for therapeutic support to provide
any guidance on navigating body and
weight changes which tricia evidently
has done oh man i really thought you
know pregnancy was just eating chips and
ice cream
and i'm like no you really have to eat
like
nutritional stuff for the baby's
development i actually had a really
swollen i don't even think i showed them
on camera i think she showed them a
little bit but my hands were so
like literally filled up with water and
it was from potato chips because i was
eating potato chips not like alarming
but i was eating like you know every day
maybe like i don't know two servings
like literally not that much well i
appreciate trisha's efforts to educate
herself on food safety during pregnancy
and reaching out to a therapist to help
her get her disordered eating in check i
also want to point out that the content
on her channel is kind of business as
usual here with approximately four
mukbang uploads within two months after
announcing her pregnancy so while any
other person who isn't familiar with
trisha's content may look at these
videos and like chalk it up to normal
pregnancy cravings given her history of
binge eating i am concerned that if this
behavior persists that it could
potentially lead to negative
consequences in her pregnancy this is
especially because research shows that
pregnant people with binge eating
disorder are at an elevated higher risk
of gestational weight gain gestational
diabetes preterm delivery and higher
birth weight than folks that do not have
binge eating disorder while folks with
bulimia symptoms are at a greater risk
of gestational diabetes and miscarriage
pregnant folks with eds are also at an
increased risk of perinatal mood and
anxiety disorders and are more likely to
experience prolonged physical and mental
health recovery postpartum even folks
without diagnosed eds can experience
challenges when they eat chaotically in
pregnancy so blood sugars can often get
a little wonky even in healthy moms to
be so it's really important to eat
regular balanced meals and snacks every
few hours so if there was ever a reason
to shelf the mukbangs for views it would
be this lastly even though trisha did
not explicitly talk about this i also
want to quickly touch on weight gain in
pregnancy while recovering from an ed so
regular weight checks while pregnant can
be especially triggering for folks who
struggle with body image but of course
we know that weight gain is inevitable
and also very important in pregnancy so
to minimize the stress of these weight
checkups crystal recommends advocating
for alternative ways to monitor for
babies growth and development and opting
out of weight checks if they're very
triggering for you so instead of
measuring your weight you could ask your
doctor if it's possible to measure
fundal height ultrasound scans and
abdominal palpitations but most
importantly pregnant folks with eds know
that it is not their fault if they are
struggling with ed symptoms while
pregnant and it is never too late to
reach out for help i'm going to be
leaving crystal's contact information
and virtual support group down below in
the description if you need some
additional support now to close i want
to remind everyone that pregnancy should
actually be a time of abundance not
denial of course we should allow
ourselves the foods that we crave but we
also should think about how we can
nourish twice as well rather than just
eating twice as much and there are a few
key nutrients of concern here first of
course is folate from dark leafy
vegetables legumes nuts and seeds which
is key to reducing the risk of neural
tube defects and i will say that trisha
seemed to get the folate memo with her
incorporation of avocado and greens in
her tik tok day of eating here the
second main nutrient of concern is iron
so iron needs in pregnancy almost double
to accommodate the increased blood
volume iron storage for baby and support
placenta development so focusing on heme
iron like meat chicken and low mercury
fish or non-heme iron from beans lentils
whole grains fortified cereals leafy veg
nuts and seeds and then pairing those
with a source of vitamin c trisha has
some non-heme iron in her greens here on
tick tock but adding some bell peppers
or maybe some citrus segment could also
definitely help the third nutrient i
want to focus in on is calcium so
calcium is essential to help build
babies bones and teeth as well as
helping the heart nerves and muscles to
grow so foods like yogurt cheese dairy
milk calcium set tofu and fortified
foods like cereals nut milks and orange
juice are all great and while there is
some calcium in her bowl of greens she
could also add like some almonds and
cheese on top there for a little bit
more and finally speaking of key salad
additions let's chat about protein i
know a lot of us struggle with protein
food aversions in pregnancy myself
included but we do want to avoid most
protein powders due to the risk of heavy
metal contamination so ideally we want
to focus on whole food sources of
protein like tofu chicken eggs or beans
all of which also contribute to iron and
that would also make trisha's salad a
more satiating complete meal obviously
this is not an exhaustive list of the
nutrients you need in pregnancy but
these are in my opinion the ones that
most people need to focus in on so to
recap my recommendations for this one
meal that she shared on tick tock is to
make sure we've got a source of iron and
protein maybe some more healthy fats
like nuts or seeds and ideally to serve
it with some bread or another
carbohydrate like fruits or sweet
potatoes to build out a more satisfying
meal and having these balanced meals
like this throughout the day will help
to stabilize blood sugars and eliminate
the chaotic energy around food which
reduces the risk of a binge restrict
cycle and on that note i wish trisha all
of the best in her motherhood journey
and if you're interested i can follow
and report back on any more insights
postpartum but a big thank you again to
buildbar for sponsoring if you like this
video be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below on who or what
you'd like to see your view next
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]